there's a problem that needs to be dealt
with in space isn't there in our in the
Solar outer solar system
uh yes so you could uh start the story
by saying that we have been making or at
least trying to make very detailed
studies of the distribution of objects
in our solar system it makes a lot of
sense to try and map the local part of
the universe and so we have tried to
identify all of the smaller planets all
of the the small rocks which are going
around and in the process of doing so
there have been some apparent anomalies
which have been noticed we've long
thought there's been a planet beyond the
orbit of Neptune so obviously that was
first thought would be Pluto and then
all the Kuiper belt objects were found
but now in the Kuiper belt there's this
strange shepherding of some objects this
grouping of these bodies out there can't
be explained very easily you have to
have something that's like pulled them
into those orbits and one option might
be that the sun had a flyby of another
star a few million million years ago and
that might have pulled them out there
but that would have had other effects as
well so one of the options is that there
is another very heavy Planet out on the
edge of the solar system that's
essentially doing this shepherding so
everything about the large planets like
Uranus Neptune
and these are sort of maybe like 50
astronomical units
the Earth is one astronomical unit
and so this planet would lie at 500 or a
thousand so really far not only that but
it's a very large planet if it is a
planet the mass of this thing needs to
be typically around five to ten times
the size of the Earth has this part of
the sky where we've got this clustering
of debris got a name and has this has
this made-up Planet got a name uh yes so
uh the class of objects that we
typically talk about are called a
transnet tuning objects because they
like way past Neptune and the planet or
this object typically goes under the
name of planet nine what myself and my
collaborators were interested in were
asking could this be something other
than a planet essentially what you need
to do is add a new massive object in the
outer part of the solar system and make
it hard to see since these are the two
characteristics we know of planet nine
and a few candidates sprang to mind
immediately we know there should be this
class of objects in the universe called
Dark Matter dark matter is essentially
at least we think it should be some set
of particles which are very difficult to
see so if you could form clumps of dark
matter these things could reside at the
edge of the solar system if they get
caught through the evolution of the
solar system another possibility which
is the one we focused on in the actual
paper was the possibility that this
could be a small black hole there's a
particular class of black holes called
primordial black holes I cannot tell you
how much I want this to be a real thing
like the idea that the solar system
could have its own little like pet black
hole like it would be the best present
like the universe could ever get me I'm
in a black hole in the solar system and
the idea is
that perhaps the reason we haven't found
planet nine is planet that could be at
the virage of the solar system is
because it's not a planet it's one of
these primordial black holes so black
holes that weren't formed by Supernova
but in the very early days of the solar
system and you had all these random
fluctuations going on and there might
have just been enough matter to Clump
together there and form a black hole so
as you vary the size uh the mass of the
black hole the size varies with it uh
and in particular
um a plant Mass black hole is a
interesting uh property that it
typically has the mass scale of ordinate
every objects such as a there you go a
watermelon a watermelon size black hole
would roughly correspond to a mass of
say five to ten times the mass of the
Earth which is remarkable if you think
that you can press the entire mass of
the earth into such a small object for
either it's into that object precisely
one other thing that let us think about
this black hole is we also found one
other complementary
anomaly in experimental data so one
thing you can look for when looking for
primordial black holes is you can look
for what's called gravitational lensing
signatures there's essentially looking
for when a star goes a little bit
brighter and a little bit dimmer because
of a massive object passing in front of
it typically these are used to exclude
the existence of primordial black holes
and there's been experimental program
for the last couple of decades which has
done extremely well in showing what Mass
primordial black holes can't be dark
matter
what was interesting in 2020 when we
actually sat down to think about exotic
objects now to solar system was there as
a tentative experimental anomaly that
said that there could be Earth Mass
primordial black holes that we're seeing
doing this brightening and dimming this
gravitational lensing in the galaxy and
so one thing that got us very excited is
that we found these gravitational
lensing experiments were pointing
towards five to ten Earth Mass promoter
black holes the fact that there were
these gravitational anomalies in our
solar system that were pointing towards
a five to ten Mass object and we thought
this is a a very curious coincidence
that these two things are pointing to
the same mass range so you could
simultaneously explain two experimental
anomalies at the same time and when you
see something like that then it becomes
worth writing your paper and just
pointing pointing the separate
communities towards this work which is
identifying similar phenomena this paper
that you've been involved with is saying
maybe there's no Planet out there maybe
there's one of these primordial black
holes about the size of a watermelon
just hovering out there shepherding
these trans neptunian objects over the
other side of the solar system
preciously and it's a very reasonable
hypothesis this from the sense that all
you need to explain these strange
anomalies is a massive object there'll
be distinct ways of looking for these
primordial black holes and that would
depend a little bit on the additional
physics so one thing people have
proposed is that for instance if
asteroids were to come particularly
close to one of these black holes then
you would actually see the asteroid
breaking up around it and this could
release some visible light from that
impact you could ask what happens if I
have some dark matter and a class of pro
model black holes which is what we
anticipate and what happens is you tend
to form a dense ball of Dark Matter
around the black hole this is very
interesting because in Principle as you
increase the density of dark matter you
can actually generate observable signals
from it in a large class of scenarios
but these signals don't show up as
visible light they can show up for
instance as high energy gamma rays so
one way you could identify a black hole
that was in our solar system or in fact
a population of black holes in our
galaxy is to try and look for these high
energy gamma rays and that's precisely
what things like a fermilat telescope do
for instance if they found it tomorrow
what do you think the reaction would be
from the astronomical Community would
every telescope suddenly be pointing at
it would every Mission be sending a
space probe to what do you think the
reaction would be I think the reaction
would be one of
doubt at first like found it how have
you found it have you really found it
because if we found it it would be
through this probably this gamma ray
Annihilation so there would be people
going you sure we can't explain this in
another way I don't think there'd be
full acceptance if it was found tomorrow
sending a probe would be an interesting
one because I don't think we'd be around
to see it arrive if it was something
there that it could arrive to so it
would be one of those missions that
would be for the next Generation but the
idea I mean can you imagine the amount
of physics you could do if you had a
black hole on your doorstep I think
they'd build a space station there like
they have at the South Pole it'd be like
it'd be like they'd build us they'd
build a an observing station right next
to it for a thousand years yeah you just
send loads of probes to orbit it for
yeah ever more and just observe what
would happen and send stuff in and just
watch it get spaghettified and test
general relativity our current best
theory of gravity in in a way we've
never ever been able to before
I think that's just why yeah okay it'd
be really really really cool for the
solar system to have a pet black hole
but at the same time like the physics
that it would open up if it were true
would be incredible you know as
scientists it's drilled into you that
you know anything that you do it has to
be you know completely bias free it has
to be independent you have to approach
it completely with no conceptions of
what to expect going in and I'm just too
biased I want there to be a black hole
so much in the solar system that I could
never ever work on this I wouldn't be I
wouldn't be impartial enough let's put
it that way
it seems quite easy to just sit here and
think hmm maybe it's a black hole I'll
write that down and publish a paper but
I've had a look at the paper and it look
it looked quite technical you haven't
just sat there with your friends and
dreamed up something and thought yeah
that would be cool if that was real
there seems to be some rigor to this
well I mean when you are want if you
want to write something like this you
need to be able to make a testable
prediction and so what we were trying to
do is we were trying to say there is a
great experimental program looking for a
planet in the outer solar system but it
need not be a planet there are other
exotic objects that we believe exist in
fact we have great experimental evidence
that dark matter should exist for
instance and really if this object's not
a planet then this is an opportunity to
use some distinct experimental
techniques to try and look for new
classes of object and so to really try
and narrow down on what is going on in
the outer solar system what would you
bet on if you had to bet your house
a planet or a black car I know you've
written the paper about a black hole and
but you're not saying you're definitely
right what what feels more I would say I
would say there's a layer there is a
layered hypothesis here
um the most extremely beneficial uh but
most highly respective scenario is that
it's a black hole in the outer solar
system the Tamer scenario is that there
is a new planet to be discovered which
it would already be an extremely
exciting Discovery
um
but again even that is still very
speculative
um there is also we all as as a
scientist you always have to think about
um things such as selection bias perhaps
we see these clusterings because
um it's easier to see one part of the
sky or it's just a snapshot in time and
yes it probabilistically is highly
unlikely for objects to Cluster uh but
uh it can happen it's the probability of
this is not zero there are good
Arguments for thinking there's an object
now to solar system but the uh let's say
the the tamus solution is that we're
just we're just seeing some on you
something that's unusual
and perhaps there's just some small
extra body in the solar system so but I
think that the real story here is is
that there is still a lot to learn about
our solar system currently and it's
really important to invest money to sort
of understand the structure and history
of the solar system especially going
Beyond Neptune but and also there are
many answered questions in terms of
early Universe cosmology and fundamental
physics and
what's interesting is if you can tie
some things together then not often you
can make progress on on interesting
points
be sure to check out the video
description I've put a link to James and
his collaborators paper about whether or
not planet nine may be a primordial
black hole and while you're there
there's also a link to Becky's latest
book it's called a brief history of
black holes
well worth a raid
and while you're at it we've got a whole
playlist of black hole videos from 60
symbols I'll include a link to that as
well if
an olive the background flow it seats
the speed of the perturbation I don't
know if you can see it can you see it